y la palma cumple un mes de la hoy se
misas el volcán cumbre vieja inició un
proceso eruptivo fuerte el 19 de
septiembre ese mismo día y por el plan
de emergencias volcánicas de canarias se
decretó el estado de emergencia
el presidente español llegó a la palma
un día después de su erupción cuando la
lava del volcán ya acaba con las
primeras edificaciones quiero trasladar
el compromiso total el compromiso
rotundo de que esté esta erupción no va
a hacer que haya gente que se quede
atrás que se quede dañada desde el punto
de vista económico diez días después la
lava del volcán llegó al mar provocando
un miedo por las consecuencias en el
ecosistema marino y también
desprendiendo unos gases sumamente
tóxicos afectando la calidad del aire de
ciertas partes de la isla
las cifras dan cuenta de la magnitud de
la erupción volcánica hasta el momento
ha destruido cerca de 1800 edificaciones
y ha obligado a 7000 personas a
abandonar sus hogares además ha cubierto
754 hectáreas de tierra gran parte de
ellas dedicadas al cultivo también ha
acabado con cerca de 60 kilómetros de
carreteras se calcula que los daños
suman una cifra de 200 un millón de
euros sin embargo a un mes de erupción
no ha cobrado la vida de ninguna persona
el gobierno se ha comprometido a
entregar un plan de reconstrucción y hoy
aprobamos en un tiempo récord el primer
real decreto-ley el segundo perdón real
decreto-ley en relación con ayudas a los
afectados por un importe global de
214 millones de euros el volcán entró en
una fase de estabilidad y lentitud sin
embargo autoridades de la palma han
afirmado que no tiene perspectiva de
mainar